think he belongs behind the board more
so than anywhere else even if he doesn't
win here which I don't think he will
um it's still very good I think it's
going to bring in more people who
perhaps have who haven't been paying
attention to the last like 10 to 15
years I know it's recently for
spectators but it's also extremely
exciting those players at least speaking
pretty much I've only played one
official game
in a bliss tournament against him which
I won so I'm excited to
deal done that
I find it hard to believe that he would
not come here incredibly well prepared
but still I have no idea what to expect
with the 12 year layoffs there's one
Gary that I remember
and uh
he was just one of the most competitive
well-prepared players and very very
intense I think the intensity is still
going to be there when I grew up I saw a
lot of his ears then read a lot about
him so he's an inspiration for me when I
studying the game so I think it's gonna
be really exciting